apporte ses bouquets que tu m'avais
cueilli sert aux saisonniers ce jasmin
et celis attacher une couronne alentours
de ma tête
gagnon ce jour ici trempont notre trépas
peut-être que demain nous ne revoie
rompt pas bonsoir et bienvenue ici à
quelques kilomètres de vendôme au manoir
de la possonnière la maison natale de
pierre de ronsard le poète de ronsard
nunes connaissant finalement qu'un seul
verre mignonne allons voir si la rose et
de ronsard lui même quasiment rien alors
commençant par les fondamentaux la guide
des lieux
valérie martel nous pousse les portes du
manoir de la possonnière bienvenue au
manoir de la possonnière la maison
natale du poète pierre barouh ça
[Musique]
nous sommes ici dans la grande salle la
pièce principale et cette cheminée
monumentale abondamment sculpté vous
raconte qui était le père de pierre de
ronsard loïs de son prénom qui a
travaillé pour le roi françois 1er
on aperçoit d'ailleurs en hauteur le
semis de fleurs de lys et le blason
royal pour bien montrer son allégeance
au roi en dessous le blason de la
famille qui demande une petite
explication ce blason est ornée de 3 à
ross c'est le nom des poissons à
l'origine cette famille s'appelait
retard petit à petit le nom va évoluer
roussard puis ronsard le père du poète
portant ce nouveau nom il fait sculpter
ce que l'on aperçoit en dessous de
l'inscription des armes parlante un
rébus culte et des ronces les arbustes
avec les petites fleurs et en bas des
flammes des ronces dans le feu des
ronces ardente
voici comment on présente ce nom de
ronsard
loïs écrivait lui même de la poésie
mais il est dit également que loïs
lorsqu'il s'est aperçu que pierre
enfants commencent à écrire de la poésie
lui a dit arrête tu ne gagneras jamais
ta vie avec ça
[Musique]
nous sommes ici ça se voit dans une des
pièces troglodytiques qui correspondent
aux comme en fin de compte du manoir de
la possonnière et voici un des endroits
où pierre de ronsard au fond il avait
une dizaine d'années adorait jouer et
bien évidemment ça lui est resté en
mémoire puisque beaucoup beaucoup plus
tard il écrira ces quelques vers je
n'avais pas 12 en eau profonde et
vallées dans les haute forêt des hommes
reculé dans les autres secrets de
frayeur tout couvert sans avoir soin de
rien je composais des verts donc on voit
que la nature environnante
que ce soit les pièces troglodytiques au
même titre que la forêt de gastines qui
est juste au-dessus l'a considérablement
inspiré lorsqu'il était jeune et
d'ailleurs il publiera un recueil de
poésie le premier les odes pour on peut
lire la majorité des poèmes chantant
tout cette nature vendômoise
alors merci valérie marcel pour cette
visite du manoir de la possonnière en
comprend mieux ainsi finalement à la
fois l'individu et puis la psychologie
des individus se pierre de ronsard qui
n'est ici et qui grandit jusqu'à l'âge
de 12 ans et ce fameux départ on est
dans les jardins alors le jardin
évidemment n'ont rien à voir avec ce
qu'ils étaient à l'époque mais quel est
le lien finalement indéfectible entre
pierre de ronsard et se vendent au mois
dans cette partie du 16e siècle
je vais vous dire une chose toute simple
alors vous savez probablement qu'il est
enterré au prieuré de saint côme qui est
al arish à côté tour
or quand il était beaucoup plus jeune il
nous explique qu'il veut être enterrés
tout près d'ici
à vol d'oiseau c'est en face de la
possonnière c'est à la sortie du village
l'isle-verte alors il n'a jamais pu être
enterré sur cette île puisque son frère
aîné a revendu cette petite terre mais
ça montre à quel point il est
extrêmement attaché à ces lieux même si
le manoir de la possonnière ne lui
appartient pas il veut être enterré
pratiquement en face
l'aspect de pierre de ronsard qui m'a
beaucoup ému c'est ce dont on parle
pratiquement depuis tout à l'heure c'est
son lien avec la nature
et quand il écrit puis du livre ennuyé
je regardais les fleurs feuilles tiges
rameau espèces et couleurs et l'antre
coupe mans de leurs formes diverses
pintes de sang façon jaune rouge et perd
ce ne me pouvant soûlé ainsi quand un
tableau d'admirer la nature et ce
qu'elle a de beau merci beaucoup valérie
martel on quitte ronsard à regret je
vous lis et demain nous irons dans le
berry et nous parlerons d'un monument il
faut le dire de la littérature française
le grand meaulnes d'alain fournier